Hey, what's up guys and welcome to the old hunters DLC. It's finally here!
I think I've played through about a quarter of it so far
and I just want to share that hunt with you. New weapons, new bosses, new NPC's. And,
hopefully a new understanding of the hunters who were around when the hunt first began.
So let's hunt through it all together and let's see what we can find
Defeat Vicar Amelia and the Messengers will bring you two items
first, the eye of a blood-drunk hunter. The pupil has collapsed here which indicates the onset of the scourge of beasts a
Hunter who goes drunk with blood is said to be taken by the Hunters nightmare
Destined to Wander forever engaged in an endless
nightmarish hunt...no Hunter can Escape this fate apparently.
The second item is the old Hunter Bell countless Hunters have passed through the dream
but cannot forget the 'thrill of the hunt'
The messengers relay these thoughts and if you ring the bell by their side then the hunters are sure to listen
for the night of the hunt is long and
Unchanging and this bell closes the gap between worlds with these items in your inventory
The Amygdala outside Cathedral Ward will take you to the Old Hunters Nightmare, but unlike the old Hunters before us
We go there as a hunter who has not completely
Succumbed to bloodlust. That's not what sucked us in what sucked us in was this creature that we know is capable of teleporting you
curse the fiends..their children too and
their children forever true.
If there's an answer for that dialogue, I haven't found it yet
I don't know who it belongs to. Who is this woman to place a curse upon people, and
What curse is she placing? We should remember this for another episode.
We arrive in a distorted version of Cathedral Ward and it's
surroundings
And maybe distorted is the wrong word though? To me this area strikes me as badly
remembered. Imagine if you had to construct a place from memory. You wouldn't get it 100% correct would you? and
To me, I kind of like to think that whatever hosts this nightmare had trouble remembering the towers in the distance
so the Towers appear tilted and illogical and
Gaps in memory are replaced by these rocky hills where there should be man-made paths instead
But this world, this nightmare. It's inhabited, just like all the others were you know Micolash's
nightmare was inhabited by the
Puppets that he pulled into the nightmare with him and also by random Hunters who made their way in as well
The Geography might be a reconstruction from somebody's memory
But the people within it
Aren't. This nightmare is full of Old Hunters.
Some of the first people to ever fight against the beasts in the first hunts that ever happened. Hunters who according to the eye
"Lost themselves to bloodlust and were pulled into a nightmare where the hunt never ends" and this shows in the gameplay
The Hunters and the beasts here are constantly fighting one another and you can use that to your advantage
The beasts are weak compared to the Hunters
but there are so many! So I like to take out the hunters while they're distracted with the beasts and
Once you're done with the hunters. You can equip a torch and deal with the beasts. They'll rarely attack you
All of these hunters are wielding weapons and wearing a guard that isn't seen in Modern-day
Yharnam you'll find pieces of their equipment throughout the early level and the old hunter garb in particular is funny, its
Description details the superstitions of the first Hunters how some hunters believed that the "Beastly plague
Crept up the right leg" so they wrapped a bit of belt around the right leg of their trousers
Some thought that bits of metal on their gloves could ward away the beast's blood and...you get the picture
They were superstitious bunch back then
The just beast tells us that: "one day the hunters disappeared drunk with blood they would pass onto the nightmare
Every last one of them." I wonder what's pulling them in?
Regardless, these hunters were around in the first days of the hunt and this nightmare contains people and the places that
existed when the hunt first began
And I really think that inside it, we'll find the answer to what started the hunt, and why. On this little crop of land
We find our first new weapon, which is the Beast Cutter
it's like a crude more brutal version of the Threaded Cane. The weapon is described as:
"Regrettably inelegant", which suggests that the earliest hunts were clumsy and Bloody and brutal which
Certainly wouldn't have helped these hunters
resist the bloodshed.
Perhaps the refinement of weapons wasn't just so you could deal with beasts efficiently, it would be so you could deal with them more cleanly
Anyway, the world here is full of Twin Bloodstone and later Bloodstone Chunks as well,
so if you want to choose a new weapon to upgrade, it could easily be one of these you find in the early DLC and
the DLC continuously bombards you with new weapons,
which I really like. It's not like the core game that gives you all the cool weapons at the very end
There are some good weapons at the very start of this DLC, and you find a new one
What feels like...every 15 minutes or so.
So far, most of my enemies have been humanoid not beasts, or monsters so as a result I definitely recommend the blunderbuss
Over something like the pistol.
I've always found that the pistol misses too much against human enemies, like you can't riposte them very well
so you might want to go with the blunderbuss...and I find the blunderbuss is better at taking out all the Hunters and
If I'm making this look easy
it's because I've been through here before! I accidentally played through all of this stage on a new game+
Character and holy shit this area in new game+ is tough enemies have so many more hit points
I actually got up to the first boss on my new game+ character and completely forgot that I was in new game+
But the first boss really reminded me of that.
I still haven't beaten the first boss on my new game+ character, and I was going to show you guys that playthrough
But my PC decided to corrupt the footage instead
So this character who is not in new Game+ is so much easier by comparison.
My recommendation to you guys is: that if you have a new game+ character,
And if it's below level 60, like mine was don't expect to get the first boss without a hell of a fight.
Choose your character wisely...and look! It's the Cleric Beast! Here comes a boss fight right? ...Any second now
Okay, maybe it starts when I pick up the item? No? No okay, then maybe it starts when I leave? No?
It doesn't? ..Didn't expect that. Maybe later?
Anyway, the Eye Pendant the Cleric Beast was holding reads: "Unlocks the surgery altar." The next weapon
We find is the Boom Hammer
and
It's waiting for you in front of this old guy, who is the guy that shoots you when you pick up the item in front
Of him. I'm sure you all remember that trap...I was like: "You're not gonna' fool me again!" Oh...
This is different.
The interesting part of this weapon reads: "Crush the beasts then burn them."
The brute simplicity of the Boom Hammer was favoured by Hunters with an acute distaste for beasts
This was crafted by the Powder-Keg Hunters. One of the first hunter groups and a lot of descriptions do reference these groups
Bloodborne already has a fairly straightforward timeline
It's not like Dark Souls which spans hundreds or even thousands of years.
Bloodborne's timeline seems like it happens within a century or so, in my opinion
so this DLC answers a lot of questions about the progression through all the different hunter groups and their history and
we even learned that there is a group that came before the Powder-Keg Hunters and
It's this beastly enemy we fight next that gives us this information.
He has this enhanced beasthood that I've still yet to learn about he has a way bigger moveset than the Beast Claws
Should give you. I think it's a rune that lets you get into the beast Form he's in. Anyway
He's where the central Yharnam lamp would be, where Gilbert would be if this was the real world and he drops the Firing Hammer Badge
Which I believe unlocks the timed molotov cocktails that you saw being thrown around before, and also the Piercing Rifle which
was and I quote:
"Developed by the Oto Workshop, which was the workshop that came before the Powder-Keg Hunter workshop.
"You're a hunter with your sanity aren't you?
Must have taken a wrong turn then, eh?
Well, we're more alike than you think
This is the Hunters nightmare
where Hunters end up when drunk with blood.
You've seen them before?
Aimless wandering Hunters slavering like beasts...
This is what the poor fools have to look forward to. So! Don't be brash, turn back before it's too late.
Unless you've something of an interest in nightmares?"
"Yes, as it should be hunt your beasts and think no more on the secrets of the night.
That is the very best a Hunter can do.
Just don't let the blood
intoxicate you."
You can say 'No' here. You can say 'I'm not interested in nightmares.'
But then, you can also talk to him again to give, what is supposedly the 'right' answer which is apparently: "Yes
I am interested in nightmares." Because he stops talking to you after you say 'Yes.'
"What now? Oh take my word, and turn back before it's too late.
Unless I suppose, you've taken an interest in nightmares? ...Oh
Yes, I see. You sense a secret within the nightmare, and cannot bear to leave it be as
If the spirit of Byrgenwerth lives on within you. Such inquisitive Hunters will relish the nightmare,
but beware
Secrets, are secrets for a reason and some do not wish to see them uncovered
Especially when the secrets are particularly unseemly."
This guy will appear later and he tells us to carry on further into the nightmare
But he warns us that some secrets aren't meant to be found
Secrets like down the Blood River is the Gatling-Gun hunter who attacks you in the pitch-black
With this brutal, brutal weapon that will stun-lock you if you stand anywhere near him.
I found the best way was to rotate around this rock until he takes a break from firing
then you get a few hits in, and you rinse and repeat. His gun can't fire forever, so
Start your assault on him as soon as it stops firing.
You actually get the Gatling-Gun for defeating him. It requires Blood Tinge and strength
So I'm going to bet that blood-tinged strength builds are going to be a thing now, that weapon is a beast!
I really recommend using the Hand Lantern in here further on you have to fight a small
Bloodletting Beast and
You'll actually want to see what you're shooting at, because it's important to counter this guy with a gun in your left hand
this room holds the Amygdalan arm a gruesome little trick weapon, that you can use as a short hammer or a
Sinewy-scythe-thing where one of the limbs just flows around with the ligament attached to it
From is so creative with their weapons! The next two weapons is the Beast Hunter's Saif
Which is way better than I thought it would be it just looks like a short-saw cleaver
but its simplest attacks include a lot of little dashes, and
Everyone knows how important it is in souls games to quickly close distances
It's a really underestimated weapon, I think. The next weapon is the Whirligig Saw. I love it,
just look at how you can grind down an enemy by Holding L2
this weapon belongs to Valtr, the Beast-Eater, leader of the league and
He's the old hunter you meet in the Forbidden Woods if you went and joined the League when patch
1.07 hit. The League is a co-op covenant
And I'm going to use this guy to help me in my boss fight
because I found the boss fight really tough I haven't had much sleep, so
Maybe I'm just not fighting very well
But it felt good summoning this guy this guy! This DLC is called;
"The old Hunters" after all and I might as well summon one of them, right?
It was nice feeling like I had a teammate against this guy.
So, let's fight that next boss shall we?
I'm not going to talk too much about the lore in these videos
But just quickly, Ludwig was originally the first hunter of the healing church a cleric who became one of the most gruesome
beasts. In the first phase of the fight
It's vitally important that you kind of become
familiar with his move-set and most importantly I think you have to learn where it's safe to hit him and
Where it's safe to heal. I find the best place to be attacking is his left side
because if you get behind him he'll buck at you like a horse. If you get under him he'll stamp around and
Likely kill you and if you get in front of him, he'll do these quick little slashes that are hard to predict and dodge.
Inevitably you do have to dodge through these front facing dashes, and that's what's so tough.
One of these dashes has a really long wind-up that will catch you if you dodge too early
but you have to dodge early against most of his dashes because they will combo you if you just take the hit, So
It's a tough fight because of that, you can't dodge too early
And you can't dodge too late. Your reflexes have to be on point if you're soloing this guy
Which is why I brought Valtr in. I decided that this companion Hunter was going to be my 'win' condition
he's fantastic for
distracting Ludwig
but he only has a limited amount of blood vessels so once he's healed like five times he'll stop healing and
The boss will kill him and you'll be in trouble, so like I said my 'win' condition was to keep him alive
I brought the Choir Bell along with me
And I kept healing Valtr whenever he got low. So basically I was keeping my tank alive,
I'd never fought a fight like that in Bloodborne before, so this was really fun for me
And I really wanted this NPC for phase 2 of this fight.
This is awesome. That music transition is so seamless and epic all of a sudden--Moonlight Greatsword out of nowhere!
But if you did look closely, you would have noticed that Ludwig actually had this Moonlight Greatsword
Strapped to his back all along.
It's fairly easy to dodge the swipes from this Great Sword, if he starts doing slam attacks
you dodge early, and if he starts swiping you dodge through the attacks and
During this fight, you'll have two chances to riposte him, to perform visceral attacks.
And it took me a while to figure out where to perform the Visceral attack
But eventually I realized you have to go right up to his crotch
and...yeah. The easiest way to die in this fight, is if you get caught in his huge charged-up Moonlight Wave attack
He does this quick AOE (Area of Effect [attack]) to make you dodge backwards
But then he follows it up with his slam down that creates this giant wave of moonlight
energy that just destroys
you! Look how
devastating it is! So you've got to dodge away from the initial AOE and then you've got to get right back close to him again
So you can dodge that attack, but eventually...
...I succeeded.